>> Laura: DOES HE THINK THAT
WHEN YOU YELL YOU ARE MORE
LIVABLE?
WE COULD NEVER QUESTION
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OR
"THE WASHINGTON POST" OR
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"?
THEY ALWAYS GET IT RIGHT?
OKAY, THAT HAS AN INTERESTING
THEORY.
DID YOU CATCH WHAT HE SAID?
BUT THEY ARE SAYING IS THAT IF
YOU EVER RAISE DOUBT ABOUT THE
COLLUSION NARRATIVE THEN YOU ARE
EITHER MOUTH TO MIKE GOOD FOR
ONE REPORT AND OR A TRUMP
BOOTLEGGER.
THERE IS NOTHING IN BETWEEN.
THAT IS HOW THEY ATTEMPT TO
SMEAR PEOPLE AND SHUTDOWN
DEBATES.
OUR NEXT GUEST HAS BEEN A
SKEPTIC FROM THE START AND
COFOUNDER OF THE INTERIM STEP.
GLENN GREENWALD JOINS US NOW.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS SHIFT IN THE
MEDIA.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPOSED,
NOW THEY SAY THAT EITHER BILL
BARR IS DOING A CONSPIRACY WITH
TRUMP AND MASSAGING MUELLER'S
FINDINGS WERE THAT MUELLER
HIMSELF MIGHT BE IN ON SOME TYPE
OF CONSPIRACY.
WHAT CAN WE EXPECT FROM HERE
FROM THE MEDIA THAT GOT THIS ALL
WRONG?
>> FIRST OF ALL MANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE HAD ANY HONOR THEY WOULD
GO BEFORE THE CAMERA AND HANG
THEIR HEAD IN SHAME AND THEN
APOLOGIZE TO EVERYONE THAT THEY
MUST LEAD FOR THE THREE YEARS
AND RESIGN.
IT WOULD GO AWAY NEVER TO BE
HEARD FROM AGAIN BUT THEY WON'T,
THEY ARE TO TO TO THEIR PAYCHECK
AND THE BRIGHT LIGHTS OF THE
CAMERA SO THEY WILL DO THAT.
THEY ARE KIND OF LIKE AN
APOCALYPTIC CULT, THEY PROMISED
THAT THE WORLD WILL END ON A
CERTAIN DAY AND THE DATE ARRIVES
IN THE WORLD DOESN'T ADD AN THEY
ARE CONFUSED.
THAT IS WHAT MSNBC AND CNN ARE
FACING RIGHT NOW.
A VERY CONFUSED FLOCK OF PEOPLE
WHO KEPT BEING TOLD THAT IT WAS
ONLY A MATTER OF TIME FOR BOB
MUELLER SAVES THEM ALL BEFORE
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
THAT HE WILL DRAG EVERYONE OUT
IN HANDCUFFS.
HE SPECIFICALLY FOUND THAT THERE
WAS NO COLLUSION.
THEY THINK THAT THEY WERE TOLD
THERE WAS NO DEBATE ABOUT.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING NOW IS
SPINNING ALL NEW CONSPIRACY
THEORIES LIKE A PONZI SCHEME
WORK KEEPS COLLAPSING.
THEIR ARGUMENT NOW IS, WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THE MUELLER REPORT.
ALL WE HAVE SEEN AS WILLIAM
BARR'S REPORTS ON WHAT IS AND IT
SO THEY ARE APPLYING THAT BOB
MUELLER DID FIND COLLUSION BUT
WILLIAM BARR IS LYING ABOUT IT
AND FOR SOME REASON BOB MUELLER
AND HIS TEAM OF 19 HIGH-POWERED
LAWYERS ARE TOTALLY FINE WITH
THAT.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY SILENT AND
PASSIVE AS WILLIAM BARR GOES
AROUND LYING ABOUT THE LAST 22
MONTHS OF THEIR WORK.
HOW STUPID AND GULLIBLE DO YOU
HAVE TO BE TO BELIEVE THAT, THAT
IS THE DESPERATION THAT THE
ANCHOR'S FACE.
>> Laura: SPEAKING OF CNN BY
THE WAY, CHRIS CROMWELL SAYS NOT
A CHANCE WOULD HE EVER APOLOGIZE
LAST NIGHT WHEN RUDY GIULIANI
BROUGHT UP THAT POSSIBILITY.
HE RIDICULED HIM AFTER HE LEFT
THE SHOW WHICH IS LOW CLASS.
THIS IS WHAT CNN'S COVERAGE
LOOKS LIKE FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVEN'T CAUGHT IT OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS.
>> I WANT TO READ THE DEFINITION
OF TREASON.
>> HE SAID IT WAS TREASON.
>> ANOTHER TUNNEL TRUMP SENIOR
HAS LIED THROUGHOUT THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> THIS GOES THROUGH THE HEART
OF EVERYTHING WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
YOU COLLUSION ON THE COVER
ROUTE.
>> Laura: YESTERDAY THE
NETWORK PRESIDENT DEFENDED THE
NETWORK'S COVERAGE AND HE TOLD
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," WE ARE NOT
INVESTIGATORS, WE ARE JOURNALIST
AND ART ROLE IS TO REPORT THE
FACTS AS WE KNOW THEM WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT WE DID.
HIS JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATED THAT, THAT IS NOT A
IN OUR MASS IS UNPRECEDENTED.
YOUR RESPONSE TO HIS DEFENSE?
>> HE HAS NO UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT JOURNALISM IS NOW YOU HAVE
TO DO IS LOOK AT THE NETWORK
THAT HE RUNS TO SEE THAT.
YOU WANT TO HEAR SOMETHING SO
INTERESTING?
I SPENT A LOT OF YEARS BEING ON
CNN AND MSNBC CONSTANTLY.
I USED TO GET INVITED ON ALL THE
TIME.
IN 2017 WHEN I BEGAN TO EXPRESS
SERIOUS SKEPTICISM, THIS CASH
COW THAT THEY'RE PEDDLING EVERY
DAY, THEY BANNED ME FROM GOING
ON THEIR NETWORK.
IT IS NOT JUST ME, OTHER
JOURNALISTS WHO WERE EXPRESSING
SKEPTICISM.
LOTS OF OTHER PEOPLE WHO WERE
BANNED BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO
DECEIVE THEIR AUDIENCE INTO
BELIEVING THAT THE ONLY ONES WHO
QUESTION WHAT THEY WERE FEEDING
THEM EITHER THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE OR HARD-CORE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
THEY LIED NOT JUST OF THEIR
AUDIENCE BUT WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED, THEY DID IT ON PURPOSE
TO KEEP ANYBODY WAS QUESTIONING
THEM OFF THE AIR.
THEY ARE RIGHT, THEY ARE NOT
INVESTIGATORS, THEY ARE NOT
JOURNALISTS, THEY ARE PROPAGANDA
AND FRAUD.